all right funny thing to say but this
like South by is loaded with people that
are building apps and building pieces
but don't know how to make money mom
does it kind of garlic right come around
is like a vision board happy with
clarity husband like my name is Gary
Thomas I've been telling you how
accountant celebrity
I'm triple-a given a pedigree second
beam and a special effects OC putting
the work that I'm doing are the moving
furniture 11 you love the place you're
looking at on the front I could see it
okay I'll see that I'm running late for
something
okay I want you right why isn't my
clothes I'm always doing of is called a
blog richer well it's working quite well
it's the foundation of my future success
exactly yeah listen thank you you're
welcome
I hear you out there put that I look for
to be on your own language
me too yeah thank you Nigel hey how we
get the dress in there I'm going to try
out yeah
[Music]
but that was good right five so what I
speak for ten minutes for Comcast how's
it going so far
good rough maybe Russian chatter you see
you coming Ben thank good hello yeah
yeah oh oh yeah you guys know each other
oh hey sorry she won the trip in Detroit
yeah and then she was like [ __ ] for that
I gotta go somewhere else I'm not going
on Troy ah
how are things getting do not you know
if I go real help let me know
thank you good to see that can you watch
his house ready go
I love the recall I know everything
sighs what about the epic epic email
townhall I did
what do you think first I guess good to
see you hi Cathy am I gonna hurry hey
Jen Barry hey Abbott how are you yup you
want to see can't a Comcast right now
they're calling it so going to see them
for a quick meeting gave a keynote this
morning
Fargo really well
a semester earlier thank you brother I
got a selfie with your course thanks to
safe Jeff thank you
your pantry how are you do I call you in
that earlier thank you
thank you she's really awfully good
about being loud really much I do
good luck to you mr. Spock very well
thank you connected to you oh yeah yeah
we were doing all this stuff here
awesome hamster
it's really cool ya know and I saw yeah
look hello Jess are you are Mike okay
total blog yes when I watched it yo you
better tag me such a hustler
you tell me I told you I know listen I
get it I get it
learning I get you are you high come
back okay I'm all ready Mike for my blog
I'm Matt yeah double my chest Ellen are
you can do agree well love and your
Facebook Thank You Man you know her I
know how are you I'm good really good
yeah I love ketchup I love tomato just
like I can't you're good I'm going to
want a big introduction oh no I'm waste
you aware of that you need water
yes I just a timer I know to give them
out yeah here's your progression is wear
fancy lot of cameras
we thing we need the [ __ ] out so quietly
so quiet hey brother
could it feel you well good to see you
now your 3ds maybe also let me know
you're not very ordinary balance between
your own personal brand and you know he
was awful economy and employees all that
I run my company on this video of an 800
person hundred thirty million dollar a
year business and that takes up all my
time
the garyvee thing is my side hustle I
have a team that supports content in
blog form reunion here whose right to
the mercy rock d-roc films we make a
vlog in that we have 18 hours worth of
content that's happening a lot of those
turn into my medium posts a lot of those
turn into my mean videos a lot of those
turn into my audio podcast I don't have
time to build a personal brand I don't I
don't time I live my life as an
entrepreneur and I don't win on being
attractive or funny I went on being an
operator and being write about things
that are happening and that's just my
day-to-day life and then we produce it
at home but I spent all my time running
my company when I do public speaking
that's business development for
vaynermedia it's a lot more funny to get
a three million dollar scope doing a
keynote at the AMA than being part of an
RFP process that's a smart business you
go house
do what I did for the first 30 years of
my life build a business that allows you
to afford one you know like I look I
think I sure like I think a lot of
people forget about my narrative because
of my feel in this in this genre I spent
the first 15 16 years of my life
building an actual wine retail business
before I even said one word to the world
about my business thoughts I didn't come
out the womb and say I'm an influencer I
built an actual business and I talked
about building businesses the thing I
tell everybody in this room and people
watching at home like self-awareness is
a big part of this as well you have to
know what you're good at and what you're
not good at the amount of people that
have started video shows because their
video marketing is good but they're
scared to be in front of a camera and
they're awkward that's just not a good
strategy it's not your normal place like
you have to know yourself and so even
though the mediums were there I could
have been a blogger I just knew that I
couldn't communicate very effectively in
the writing format and so I punted it
kept building a business and then when
short-form Twitter when video for
youtube came out I'm like that I think I
can do and that's what I jumped into
sales and marketing I've been doing it
for four decades I'm so much more old
school than they think
well would you go through I mean there's
a little picture of it a hundred percent
even even on stage I've got to be more
simplistic than I like it but you need
to use there for the crash yeah exactly
real nice to meet you take care so
sapphires going super well had a great
client meeting were you in the client
meetings contest no quick lion meeting
and great keynote it seems like people
are really enjoying it you rock you even
liked it which is rare and exciting and
I didn't play super well basketball I
didn't play well at all
that's right delft husband on the course
of nine months and work on that and then
get some Vayner sports recruiting which
is fun can't show that hey Joe Joe how
are you mouth on yogurt very nice a good
juice back of the day when you were
thank you brother you're on good get up
on that - Thank You Man I actually call
you an abjad food thank you miss and
crazy to see your evolution thank you
awesome and I'm running late for
something buddy sent a love thing good
luck to you figure yo so gosh yes I
guess yes [ __ ] thank you
real funny dude how are you sorry don't
worry yeah from the back you got
hustling lotion trunk on me we're a
[ __ ] worker another man another me
like that I love it wait yeah let's do
it
do you know I've read that program oh
yeah he is a Brokaw
[Laughter]
[Music]
you too man thank you very beautiful
thank you very well super busy
we're already been lair can't find you
[Applause]
I'm pushing practicality you know we got
eight years of a good economy like this
world of ours and this is Kim I mean if
you're here you're ambitious you know
what's going on in new world your
Heights you've got a lot of energy on
Memorial you're risk-taker the problem
is from when I look at this crowd
there's so many young people who never
lived through the punch in the mouth you
know so after eight you know after eight
great years in our economy I just I want
people to pay attention to actually
making money you know users and
engagement and followers those are you
know lifetime value tack all this stuff
that people talk about in the startup
world is all nice and dandy but if your
business is not making money one month
and it's losing money you're not going
to be raising money when there's none
out there and so I'm pushing
practicality of boring but it's
tried-and-true because it requires them
in events where you look at in this
world in the South by world I look for
the jockey over the horse so I'm looking
at does she have the fire to change her
business nine months in when the market
changed on her so in start-up land it's
hard but let me tell you guys how all to
make money no joke if you're sitting on
money every person here should invest in
Facebook and then when the world melts
in nine months and the stocks in half
and you hate me don't sell it just hold
on because I promise you in nine years
that investments going to return you a
boatload of money so that's the slow
double or triple your money bet but
that's kind of better than the [ __ ]
zero interest you get in the back the
way to make crazy money is the only bet
on the jockey because they've got a
pivot they've got to adjust you know to
operator the pilot she and me is the one
that's going to dominate and win because
the reality is these startups are so
young and early like Facebook looks
nothing like what Facebook looked like
nine years ago he made a bunch of
adjustments like this [ __ ] changes and
you've got to be used to that but if I
had to adjust
Birchbox has to adjust like like
everybody's navigating and just raising
capital or
in the park so I'm looking for somebody
who can get punched in the mouth spit
the blood out and move forward good all
right I didn't know I said I like that
and again looking at the demo you have
to be the architect and the farmer right
and the mason and the garbage person
like like the thing that I have a lot of
pride in is I can come on and talk all
high level and then when somebody calls
me to the mat like you guys the reason I
love you is I knew a lot of [ __ ] and I
just pontificate and nobody calls me to
the mat we run out of time and I leave
you called me to the matter like okay
and but what I'm excited about is that's
my best moment because we want to go
into details I'll get so finite into
that detail so to me the one thing I
would pride myself in as you grow in
your business as you grow the thing that
I have the most pride in is vaynermedia
now is 800 employees not one of them
that work for me does has met much
actual social medias I do I'm still by
far and that's what but probably the
biggest reason my side hustle is Gary
Vee is because it keeps me grounded in
actually the doing of the [ __ ] that I'm
doing and what happens to a lot of
people as they grow they get away from
the work and they become a manager and
then they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about ah yeah you really
am gonna see it okay good good that it
is it yeah let me sit down and on
Autofac yeah we will show you yeah what
up nd you see my man is always Korea you
see this card boy slideshows of a sign
people don't rhyme what's your name
again
everything goes he's filming boy still
making some cash on a side flipping yes
you go out you don't eat what I is
making slime in summer yes why I'm
killing that's killing Mike Mike Mike
this my daughter to the whole subways
what how I see is a well-known yes all
all the angles
go to school and this line when he said
the other day came up when I wanted 20
on how to take it back my my my name is
Gosling and he's like my dad
now when I'm going to just use everyone
at a time and when I finish those the
ones I like right but I haven't seen
that Connor that's not what you have
what you like no really it is the one I
have totally lost this one to a bad
state remember so you said document
hundred forty thousand dollars and next
ninety days you know people think I'm
making up [ __ ] this guy commentators
like it took a lot of sweat right my boy
dick is up there you look she's supposed
to take what I don't we gotta go okay
what's already the wrong I just want to
say I am very jealous
[Music]
thank you guys know we're close right
and doesn't stop 27 days long for me
there's an odd [ __ ] that was perfect
Donna you know I would say let's go make
some actual money because shits about to
hit the fan and half making money is a
very good strategy
alright funny thing to say but this like
South by is loaded with people that are
building apps and building ceases but
don't know how to mix - give it up for
daddy
ah God is one fill up man yeah hi guys
all right you're welcome
what are you trying to get out of some
poppers why do you enjoy it I show up
for two core reasons one there's just a
shitload of people here and I curse
affordable okay so just a lot of people
here to sleep that last part and just
even having this and shaking hands and
meeting people that you only get to see
once in a while and - a lot of my
business associates congregate here so I
get 11 meetings today that would have
taken me four months to schedule and I
did them all in one afternoon so it's
actually efficient for me to show off
the South line so people like those well
it's you being Wow
I'm laughs and confident I'm confident
with like being an asus or whatever yeah
so what scares scary be my creepy night
were scared you the health and
well-being of my family is 100% when it
comes to business I know that I'll end
up being historically correct I'm
empathetic to somebody seeing me cursed
in a video like this or act too proud
and they'll be like he's full of hot air
they're even going to be right or I'm
going to be right in 20-30 years and I
know what my intent is I'm not trying to
hurt anybody feeling I understand that
my Jersey this might be too crass for
somebody but I'm not going to change who
I am because of the way you see the
world
I respect for the way you see the world
have some for me you're about to sharing
you like that right are you okay where
you pick I would pick my two dead
grandfather's because I never met them
and I would pick Randy the Macho Man
Savage who also is dead
because my favorite all-time restaurant
yes the last time our government
economist up I'm humbled every day being
on or is coupling 24/7 365 don't get it
twisted for online bravado and all my
ego I live on humility because I'm
losing every second there's problems I
got 800 pop by the time I got off save
yourself I have 800 humbling moments in
my phone right now when you run big
companies your home of all the time I
love being home
I enjoy being humble that's part of the
process we sing the song get in danger
why [ __ ] pleasure coming in Tuesday
just beginning there you go people kept
Wednesdays all week City Thursday all
hands Friday on an internal [ __ ] going
on you're supposed to be in Austin
Tuesday we clear that out
[Music]